bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
journal de l'afrique à la une de cette
édition le tchad un an après la mort
d'idriss déby le dialogue national tant
attendue a été repoussée nous irons à
n'djamena en début de journal
les guinéens devront attendre aussi pas
d'élection n'est de retour à un pouvoir
civil dans l'immédiat la transition va
durer au moins 39 mois prévient le
colonel m'hamdi doumbouya l'opposition
dénonce d'ores et déjà une décision
arbitraire
puis enfin nous irons au sénégal dans
cette édition les célébrations de l'aïd
ont un goût particulier cette année
l'inflation due à la guerre on ne traîne
pèse sur le porte monnaie des habitants
reportage en fin de compte
c'est un dialogue qui devait poser les
bases de la réconciliation nationale au
tchad un an après la mort du président
idriss déby le projet a été repoussé le
gouvernement de transition n'a pas donné
de nouveaux calendriers ont fait le
point avec notre correspondant mamadou
et jim tb
ce dialogue qui doit regrouper partis
politiques ce site et civils et groupes
rebelles est donc reporté pour la
troisième fois il faut dire que ce
report était réclamé par les acteurs de
la société civile les groupes
politico-militaires et l'opposition dite
radicale notamment le mouvement va
quitter match qui a même quitté le
processus geci pour manque de sérieux
pour beaucoup la date du 10 mai était
intenable les préparatifs ne sont pas
encore terminées et il serait impensable
que cette grande messe c'est yen à
l'absence de mouvement rebelle sans
accord de paix leur présence n'djamena
et est hypothétique sans leur
participation et quelques acteurs
critique de la junte ce dialogue
perdrait de son caractère inclusif pour
presse et au qatar de demander ce
rapport cela étonne et interroge ici à
djamena le qatar joue le rôle de
médiateur pour les négociations entre
gouvernement et 51 mouvement révèle tous
discutent depuis un mois et demi à doha
la capitale qatarie
objectif aboutir à un accord de paix
mais les discussions semblent piétiner
c'est cela qui a motivé la raquette du
gouvernement qatari à laquelle le chat a
donné une suite favorable
j'ai site afin de donner aux différentes
parties plus de temps pour parvenir à un
accord de paix en vue de la convocation
du dialogue national inclusif à djamena
la société civile et l'opposition se
disent satisfaits de ce report à lui
promet un dialogue national mais sans
aucun parti politique en tunisie qui
cède affirme qu'il sera mené par quatre
formations il s'agit du quartet qui
avait reçu en 2015 le prix nobel de la
paix pour sa contribution à la
transition démocratique
le président tunisien qui je le rappelle
s'est accaparé l'été dernier tous les
pouvoirs et qui a dissout fin mars le
parlement on écoute un extrait de sa
prise de parole
aux maladies mentales des tas d'habits
pour travailler sur les questions liées
aux mesures extraordinaires
un comité sera formé dans le but de
préparer l'établissement d'une nouvelle
république si jolie qui terminera son
travail un peu de temps en temps
quelques jours tony parce que les
questions sont claires et les choix sont
d'office
mardi
le dialogue ne sera pas ouvert une
troisième fois à ceux qui ont vendu leur
âme
qui n'ont aucun patriotisme à ceux qui
ont apporté la ruine qui ont affamé et
maltraité le peuple ou allemann chaouaou
où aller mal la colonne chat
c'est une transition politique bien plus
longue que prévue en guinée le colonel
au pouvoir mamadou doumbouya annoncé que
le retour au pouvoir des civils ne se
ferait que dans trente neuf mois
plusieurs partis politiques et membres
de la société civile rejette d'ores et
déjà cette proposition écouter malik
diakité est à conakry pour france 24
à peine annoncé le calendrier proposé
par la jante est déjà rejeté par les
principales formations politiques et de
la société civile du pays à savoir la
nada la coalition dirigé par cellou
dalein diallo qui rassemble une
soixantaine de partis politiques le rpg
rassemblement du peuple de guinée du
président de jeu alpha condé ou encore
le fndd front national pour la défense
de la constitution pour ne citer qu'eux
selon eux cette échéance on n'a fait
l'objet d'aucune discussion consensuel
comme le prévoit l'article 77 de la
charte de la transition nous ne sont pas
d'accord c'est le chronogramme que nous
résistons nous réclamons un dialogue
franc et sincère afin que la clique 77
soit respecté pour que nous puissions
discuter et que de commun accord entre
les forces vives de la nation et le cnrd
un chronogramme consensuel puisse être
trouvée il y a des velléités claire de
confisquer le pouvoir de s'éterniser de
ne pas organiser des élections abondent
il s'agit d'un pas jules qui a été fait
par le président de la tension qui
contre toute attente a violé l'article
67 l'achat de la transition la chatte
sur laquelle lui même a prêté serment et
nous pensons qu'ils année des taux il va
falloir une mobilisation des populations
guinéennes parce que le pouvoir reste au
peuple et seul le peuple est détenteur
de ce pouvoir est ce le peuple à doigts
a choisi ses dirigeants les militaires
quant à eux ont dit que les trente neuf
mois sont une proposition consensuelle
l'issue des consultations des
consultations qui ont été boycottées par
ces partis politiques la communauté
économique des états de l'afrique de
l'ouest qui n'a pas encore réagi à ce
chronogramme de la junte guinéenne
annonce l'envoi d'une mission dans les
prochains jours à conakry
une transition politique en guinée
retardé qui inquiète antonio guterres s
il appelait avant de pouvoir aux civils
dans les délais les plus brefs le
secrétaire général des nations unies qui
est en déplacement ce lundi au niger
vous voyez sur ces images il a par
ailleurs rappelé la nécessité de faire
de ce pays l'épicentre de la lutte
contre le djihadisme dans la région on
écoute
la communauté internationale doit
investir à fond dans le renforcement des
capacités de l'armée du niger
du point de vue financier et produit des
équipements du point de vue des aspects
d'entraînement nous voyons un niveau de
financement des activités humanitaires
et de stabilisation à la baisse un
exemple le plan de réponse humanitaire
pour le niger pour l'année 2022 n'est
actuellement financé qu'à 8,7 pour cent
c'est absolument inconcevable
j'appelle tous les partenaires à vih
notre attention et notre engagement dans
la région soit maintenue malgré les
nouvelles crises qui frappent notre
monde
a le niger où près de 15% de la
population sera en situation de crise
alimentaire dès le mois de juin plus
d'un million d'enfants souffrent déjà de
malnutrition aiguë l'une des clés pour
limiter les dommages c'est l'éducation
alimentaire ou comment manger plus
efficacement avec de maigres ressources
et un reportage de notre correspondant à
rolle de gira
dont l'hôpital national de niamey le
service dédié à la malnutrition
infantile et sous tension après une très
dure sécheresse en 2021 qui a provoqué
les pires récolteuse agricole depuis
cinq ans les cas de sous alimentation se
multiplient ce petit garçon a tout juste
six mois ils n'arrivent plus à
s'alimenter correct là
c'est mon petit fils
on lui a donné des biscuits mais il ne
les mangent pas les médecins m'ont dit
de lui donner à manger mais dès que
j'essaye et le vomi tout
malgré l'aide internationale pour les
médecins ce sont les connaissances sur
une alimentation équilibrée qu'il faut
avant tout transmettre par en
sorte a dit
soldati
la prise à achat de la faune d'unity ça
ne consiste pas à donner du lait ont
délaissé pour les uns peut espérer
éviter les complications et de l'autre
côté le groupe de travail c'est surtout
ses conseils nutritionnels là qui
permettent d'éviter à la pointe de
tomber encore mal lotis des conseils qui
souvent n'atteignent pas les zones les
plus rurales
ici dans le village de malo coira ces
femmes sont venues assister à un cours
de nutrition
l'objectif préparer les aliments de la
manière la plus efficace possible
quand les rations viennent à manquer
il ne faut pas trop prévoir si l'enfant
ne mangent qu'un peu le reste finit par
pourrir il faut préparer uniquement ce
qu'il peut boire et manger
au niger plus de trois millions et demi
de personnes pourraient être en
situation de crise alimentaire d'ici
juin 2022
c'est une zone exposée aux risques
d'attaqué djihadiste le nord de la côte
d'ivoire la militarisation sur place se
poursuit malgré une relative accalmie il
faut dire que depuis les attentats de
juin 2021 la menace reste omniprésente
et le traumatisme est dans tous les
esprits et reportages de samuel bernard
c'est une route non bitumée comme il y
en a des milliers en côte d'ivoire mais
dans le nord-est du pays cet escadron de
militaires s'y déplacent lentement et en
rangs serrés
il ya trois mois un engin explosif a été
retrouvé à quelques 17 km le mot d'ordre
est donc à la vigilance
[Musique]
au bout de cette route menant au burkina
faso voisin la ville de tokyo située à
l'extrême nord du pays subit elle aussi
les conséquences des attaques jihadistes
dans la région en moins d'un an six
mille réfugiés burkinabè sont arrivés
dans cette localité de vingt mille
habitants dans cette ville les
militaires connaissent les différentes
familles qui abrite ces réfugiés comme
cet homme qui leur a ouvert largement
les portes à leur arrivée
ils sont 30 à dormir dans ses deux
salles au début ils étaient une dizaine
de personnes puis cinq personnes sont
venues puis cette personne ils sont
venus au compte gouttes jusqu'à la
situation actuelle
ces hommes en uniforme ont pour mission
d'améliorer l'image des militaires mais
aussi de garder un oeil sur ces réfugiés
à travers ces familles d'accueil
peter pouvaient nous voir comment est-ce
que ce village où vivent encore le on
n'a pas de tuteur c'est à lui offert
prochaine du barça chez toi et vit dans
le nord de la côte d'ivoire est
désormais rassemblée sous une seule
unité de commandement appelée zone nord
au poste de commandement la situation
est officiellement sous contrôle mais un
renforcement les effectifs restent
nécessaires
malgré la relative accalmie nous n'avons
pas le doigt les domiciles nos lauriers
nous avons estimé les besoins d'avoir
des effectifs additionnel et vous avez
vu que dans les actions futures nous
envisagions faire une génération des
forces afin de renforcer davantage notre
dispositif
3000 soldats ont été recrutés favril par
l'armée ivoirienne le renforcement de la
présence militaire dans le nord du pays
a vocation à se poursuivre
ce lundi les musulmans les musulmans du
monde célèbrent l'aïd au sénégal
l'ingrédient indispensable de cette fête
c'est le poulet son prix a été multiplié
par deux en l'espace de quelques
semaines à peine en cause la guerre en
ukraine qui rend le maïs et autres
aliments des volailles beaucoup plus
cher c'est un reportage réalisé à dakar
il est signé nos correspondants sarah
sakho avec elimane now
c'est paraît-il pour fatma à l'abri de
chaque côté cette mère de famille va en
personne choisir son poulet pour la fête
cette année et les surprises par la
hausse vertigineuse du prix des
volailles
c'est vraiment très cher imaginez des
poules de même pas 2 kg sont vendus 3500
francs cfa et je dois en acheter 5 pour
satisfaire toute la famille à ce prix ce
sera très dur de m'en sortir
ou sénégal près de 10 millions de
poulets sont consommées le jour de la
fête leur prix est fixé par les
producteurs cette année puis l'index
l'augmentation du coût du mil et du maïs
pour justifier la hausse des prix
[Musique]
l'aigle le kg de graines coûté 315
francs cfa maintenant il est passé à
plus de 400 francs cfa c'est une hausse
très surprenante
tant qu'agriculteur on s'en sort
difficilement on vend même parfois nous
pou la terre
le ministère du commerce de son côté
index l'inflation généralisée puis à la
guerre nucléaire nous sommes rattrapés
un peu par cette crise là qui est en
russie et qui se répercute sur la
disponibilité de ses produits la sacrée
ces situations là qui fait que bon on
pourra constater par ci et par là de
discuter en termes de prix mais en gros
l'oral demande va suivre l'offre pendant
la période de la korité pour soutenir
les ménages le gouvernement à renoncer
au droit de voile et à la tva ceux des
denrées de grande consommation comme le
sucre lune et le riz
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous d'avoir suivi on se quitte avec ses
images de célébration de l'aïd-el nous
parviennent du caire en égypte belle
soirée à tous sur france 5
[Musique]